here now former Florida attorney general
Pam Bondi Fox News contributor Tammy
Bruce Pam let's get your take on this uh
I thought Madeleine brame was phenomenal
and I think she took that committee to
task and how dare they say she's a prop
Sean this is why Americans are outraged
for situations just like this Mrs brame
is a hero she's Brave she is a grieving
mother she is why prosecutors go to law
school to prosecute cases to be able to
protect victims like her husband who was
almost mortally wounded and her son who
was fatally killed brutally killed and
as she said the homicidal Maniacs who
killed her son are walking the streets
that's why real prosecutors want to go
to court every day to keep them off the
streets and to protect people like her
and her family yet Alvin Bragg is a
disgrace and Adam Schiff and his friends
should be disgusted by the way they
treated her and Americans are outraged
because of it Tammy you live in New York
what's your reaction uh you know this is
It's remarkable to see a perfect example
of what all Americans are feeling and
what's interesting is is that these are
people who just want to be living their
lives and they're kind of pulled into
this environment because of the
corruption and we see the contempt right
we we talk about the Forgotten man and
woman and the contempt the government
feels for us but there it was on display
is that there was like no they're just
so used to having no respect at all for
the average American and they just let
it out they're just they're forgetting
that we're watching this or they don't
care there's this sense that a woman
like that has no power she and her son
don't matter there she is wearing
apparently his dog tags it's
heartbreaking but it's also very
exciting in that this is a woman like
moms across this country who isn't going
to sit back and accept this kind of
contempt and disrespect which of course
affected her son dramatically he
contributes to this country he served
this country and that's the thanks he
gets and that's the attitude she gets I
mean this was a a revelation a reminder
to the American people why we do what we
do and it transcends politics
Republicans have plenty to complain
about when it comes to Republicans but
my goodness Democrats they've got to
come forward and admit that this is not
the party that they knew it is not
representative of what will help their
families not just economically but crime
in every city whether it's blue or red
or anywhere else this mentality like a
cancer metastasizes everywhere and
Democrats like that Mom have got to
stand up and be vocal like that Bravo to
her but she is you know the politicians
make a mistake they think she might be
an outlier the fact of the matter is she
is us we are all her and they'd better
be prepared for the next couple of years
because we've had it Pam let me ask you
about Lincoln getting 51 former Intel
people to lie about 100 Biden's laptop
and the allegations of this
whistleblower which I think are very
real implicating even Mary Garland your
reaction
yeah Sean it's very frightening that
this is happening thank goodness we have
whistleblowers in this world who are
willing to come forward it's very
important it's crucial and I think I
think now the facts are going to come to
light we have to have whistleblowers
more people if you're out there come
forward don't be afraid to come forward
we now have people like Jim Jordan in
Congress who are going to protect you
and to be able to look out for you so
you can tell the truth I think it's
going to be detrimental to Hunter Biden
into blinken as it should
what's your take on that Tammy to me
this is outright lying propaganda
misinformation to influence a
presidential election the highest level
in our government these people served
yes this is uh it's very important
because the letter itself The
Whistleblower protections are only
happening because the Republicans have
the house but when it comes to that
letter this is you know we can talk
about corruption and certain people
being bad guys it's almost as though
this government is being run like a
cartel
and it's not just again I don't care
what party you belong to this is about
the Next Generation and our
responsibility
for the the tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of dead who fought for this
country right the Revolutionary War
getting worse than that because we know
the FBI was meeting with big Tech every
week telling them they may be victims of
a misinformation campaign and it may be
about Hunter Biden they have 51 former
top Intel officials right lie to the
American people is that election
interference it's a it's election
interference but what's interesting is
the seed had to be there from the start
to be able to put this together you know
it's I don't know how much convincing
they had to do of these people but I'm
going to guess not much and that's what
we have to realize these are not in the
moment one-off Dynamics this is the
result of a cancer that has been coddled
and allowed and has been able to move
forward without being pushed back on
that's the only reason they were able to
do this in front of people and then to
have be exposed and to still have no one
be taking responsibility or to have you
know any kind of Law and Order face them
as a result of this telling you that the
corrupt system that allowed that the
cancer that allowed that is still
running through the body of this country
all right Pamela coordinated effort yes
it was a coordinated effort
yeah well said I mean you know what
dangerous too all right thank you both
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else